[Music]
it's been a long time since I've been
excited about a desktop PC
I mean it's 2017 and desktops haven't
been cool since like the Bush
administration but then this happened
this is the Microsoft Surface studio
it's a desktop for people who draw and
design and make videos and generally do
things other than just use a mouse and
keyboard on their computer it is a
desktop PC but it's also a drafting
table it starts at 3 grand and goes up
quickly from there that's a lot for any
computer but if you were ever going to
yell shut up and take my money at a
computer it'd probably be this one I
mean come on look at it it's actually
not quite as powerful as you might
expect given the price it starts with a
Core i5 processor 8 gigs of RAM and a
terabyte of hybrid storage those are
laptop specs and not even particularly
impressive ones you can spec it all the
way up to crazy things like 32 gigs of
ram but even the $4,200 model still
doesn't have all solid-state storage the
SATA spec is the breakfast you're
getting a GUI the Nvidia graphics chip
but not the newest one and you'd want
all the power you can get just to make
this screen run smoothly
it's 28.1 to 5 inches 4800 by 3,200 in
resolution as is you can play most games
as long as you're not on super high
settings but this is never going to be a
VR machine or even an awesome way to
play Resident Evil 7 in case it's not
obvious from the design you can't open
an upgrade this machine for normal use
even apps like Photoshop there's plenty
of power here and this screen is really
remarkable
it is a 3:2 aspect ratio which means
it's a little taller than your average
screen this thing is to use a technical
term stupid huge you can see a dozen
apps at a time if you want it but I
really like just putting one app
fullscreen and working in it it's
peaceful you know
just as cool as the screen itself is
what you can do on it when you have it
up like this it feels like a normal
desktop you can slowly pull it down into
that drafting mode and the giant
touchscreen just comes right up under
you you can use the included surface pen
or your fingers and it just becomes the
biggest tablet you've ever seen the
studio's hinge holds it pretty steadily
at any angle which is really impressive
and the whole process just feels so into
it you sit down use the awesome Windows
hello feature that logs you in the face
recognition then pull the screen towards
you and go straight to work as you can
see the whole minimalist brush silver
aesthetic looks pretty great on your
desk since the screen has to move up and
down so much all the computer reports
are actually in the base back here
that's where all the ports are - in the
back it's nice to have all those ports
but it's super awkward that they're all
all the way back here sadly though
that's just par for the course for the
beautiful all-in-one when it's down like
this is really where the studio becomes
something new and different it's meant
to be touched and drawn on swiped around
and made all gross and fingerprinted I
put ours on a desk in our office and
people just kept wandering over to it
grabbing the pen and just going to work
we all found some pretty interesting
bugs in apps like Photoshop and
illustrator where little things don't
work the way they should but it all
seems like normal bugs after a new thing
comes out in general the whole setup is
amazingly powerful and accurate and just
fun to use in keeping with the focus on
creatives microsoft also released a new
accessory the surface style the idea is
that you'll be able to change settings
tweak colors and all of that so that
drawing and working becomes a two hand
touch kind of experience it's really
clever but not many apps support it yet
so I just use it to change volume in
Spotfire which is probably not worth the
hundred bucks yet for a lot of people
everything about the surface studio is
total overkill but it's the beautiful
wonderful I want it really bad kind of
overkill and if you're an artist or an
architect or just someone who's happier
with a pen than a mouse the surface to
do is sort of perfect it's cheaper than
buying an iMac in one of Wacom Cintiq
tablets which is what a lot of people
already do and this is better than that
it's more integrated more natural it's
the best monitor I've ever used with the
touch and hinge and all those freaking
pics
there are some bugs in the whole setup
plus some first generation weirdness the
Microsoft has to work out like those
graphics but Microsoft set out with the
surface studio to build a device that
creative people will love that they
might even consider buying over whatever
Apple product comes out next and you
know what they kind of nailed it
[Music]